foreign
[Music]
so the first question that you may be
asking in the audience today is who am I
am a marine Community ecologist by
training I'm passionate about using math
to understand natural systems and using
rstudio to do it my current work is
looking at Marine communities and how
they're responding to climate change
and so even though I'm battling a lot of
imposter syndrome to say this in front
of the room full of incredible rstudio
users in front of me today I am a data
scientist
yeah thank you
thank you
and as a data scientist and as a marine
scientist I'm very familiar with walking
into rooms and being one of very few if
any
in fact I am one of the three percent
data suggests that fewer than three
percent of data scientists are women of
color
and while I humbly stand before you all
today
pronouncing this as a success story
there are there were a number of trials
and tribulations along the way
and so I want to talk a little bit about
how I was almost lost on this journey to
data science and how I almost was not
standing in front of you all today
giving this presentation
when I started graduate school I felt
like the corner of this photo of this
beautiful illustration by Alison Horst I
was in my own little corner I didn't
know what I was doing it felt like it
was a lot of rainy days and I was
especially weighed down by the
exclusivity I felt about data science it
felt like a tool that I was using but it
didn't feel like a community that I was
a part of
I was also weighed down by the historic
exclusion of minority stem professionals
that I felt very much so in Academia
and I also was stunned at the lack of
action and support from my institution
and from Academia in general in the wake
of a call for social justice and reform
and equity in our field
and so I lost my spark
it felt like I didn't know why I was in
graduate school anymore it felt like I
didn't know why I was using these tools
anymore
but
open science saved me
it opened this landscape of community it
opened this opportunity for me to find
myself again and I found community in
our studio and its users I also
participated in the openscapes Champions
program and it changed my workflow
radically
and I discovered once again my passion
for data Science Education and also for
engaging other students as well
and so I may have said two words already
that you're unfamiliar with so I wanted
to find them quickly the first is open
science and the second is openscape
so open science is the tools and the
practices that enable all of us to have
more reproducible transparent and
inclusive practices for data intensive
science
and so when we're talking about tools
we're talking about these open source
softwares and practices that we're using
for example GitHub and we talk about the
practices as well and the communities
that exist around these tools for
example the rstudio community
and if you have the pleasure of hearing
this morning's keynote you learned a
little bit about openscapes and so
openscapes helps researchers reimagine
data intensive science and also to
develop the skills to cultivate
collaborative and inclusive teams and
they do that in two ways in particular
the first is through the openscapes
Champions program which I was a
participant in which is an open science
mentorship program for science teams
and the second is through cultivating
the openscapes mindset which is a
community building framework to support
the transition to open science
and it relies on these three principles
that turn into a cycle of community
building the first is to empower
research teams the second is to amplify
leaders and the third is to engage
mentors
and so when I participated in the
openscapes Champions program it changed
my life I was so excited to see that new
beautiful landscape of open science and
collaboration that existed and so I
asked two questions after my
participation in openscapes when we were
checking in a few months later
the first was why had I never heard of
open science before and the second was
how do I get more students like myself
to learn about open science before they
fall through the cracks in this pipeline
and so that conversation those questions
turned into a dialogue and that dialogue
has now turned into a long-term
collaboration with openscapes to support
and explore how we can support students
from historically excluded backgrounds
on their Journeys to data science
and more than that it also connected me
with an incredible community of people
with similar similarly motivated by
their values by the by valuing diversity
inclusion transparency and collaboration
and so I was all of a sudden exposed to
all of these incredible resources
especially the r Studio community and I
learned what it had to offer
and so I went from an outsider and
believing that data science was just a
tool that I used to do my work to now
being a participant in the change that
I'm hoping to see in our data science
communities
and so when we've been reflecting about
how I made it to this point and how I'm
standing in front of you all today I
thought about a formula for the success
that's led to this point the first point
being values in action the second being
investment aligned with these values and
the third being an openscapes mindset at
all levels and I'll take a moment to go
into each of these
the first is values in action it was
incredibly refreshing for me to
participate and be a part of communities
that showed me that they were walking
their talk not only is inclusivity and
transparency and collaboration a part of
the work that rstudio is doing but it's
also a part of the community and the
people who are a part of it some
examples of that include my our users
and our ladies
also being able to see and experience
the authentic leadership within the open
science community in particular with
openscapes in our studio we've had the
chance to hear from so many of the
incredible developers and leaders who
are part of these teams and it's
refreshing to see how open they are to
hearing our concerns how much a part of
they are part of this community and it
matters that all of us are working
together
and lastly action with a sense of
urgency
I don't think any of us would be here
today if we didn't believe the r Studio
Community was going to make this a safe
place
this an example of that is the code of
conduct and coveted policies for this
conference
this is my very first time giving a
non-academic talk this is my very first
time talking about diversity and equity
and that's very scary for me but I knew
that the place that I wanted to do it
for the first time was at our studio
conference
and that to me is a testament to what
this community is capable of
the next is investing in those Community
Values and I think that there are two
ways that the open science Community has
demonstrated this to me in particular
and the first is prioritizing
compensating people for their time their
effort and their contributions to safer
spaces for all of us
my work with openscapes was the very
first time in my career of working on
diversity equity and inclusion in over
six years or I was compensated for the
work that I was doing
and to me it made me less stressed that
this was a side project that I was
passionate about and showed me that I
could prioritize this in my life and
that it was a priority to the community
that I was serving as well and it made
all the difference
the next is lowering the barriers for
participation and engagement the reason
I'm standing before you all today is
that I'm a participant in the rstudio
diversity Scholars Program that made it
possible for me to be here and to
participate in workshops and present to
you all today and I think it's just one
example of the many ways that ours com
our studio Community is committed to
making sure that we get a lot of people
in these rooms having these
conversations
Additionally the resource guides and the
openness of this community to Learners
at every level is an incredible asset to
being able to bring people from all
types of backgrounds into our data
science communities I think a great
example of that is if you've ever you
know been searching for the answer to a
question that you have you've probably
stumbled upon the rstudio blog as well
and lastly is the openscapes mindset at
all levels as I mentioned there are
three tiers to this flywheel the first
is empowering research teams the second
being amplifying leaders and the third
being engaged mentors
and ultimately what this is building is
a community where at every level
regardless of hierarchy or leadership
structure that all of us are committed
to building Community all of us are
committed to mentoring and working with
one another
and ultimately we're able to build
collaboration and mentorship not only
within our organizations but beyond
it makes our work more collaborative
more inclusive it makes it Kinder and
more efficient as well
and ultimately building Community with
the openscapes mindset means that you're
not alone
regardless of if you just join the team
or you're well into your work this is a
way for us to collaborate and learn with
one another and no one has to try to fix
anything by themselves
and we can all experience and enjoy the
landscape open science has to offer
so what does it look like when we do the
work what does it look like when all of
these principles are in place what does
it look like when we we put this formula
together values in action investment
aligned with these values and lastly an
openscapes mindset at all levels
it looks like going from learner to
teacher
this is a photo of me teaching my very
first open science lecture to a cohort
of openscapes Champions that
participated after I did
it looks like expanding our open data
and open principles to communities
beyond our own and I was able to host an
event in other communities that I'm a
part of this year I hosted in a data
science mixer for black and Marine
Science another organization that I'm a
member of and I was able to bring
together quantitative Marine scientists
to build community and talk about open
science and explore how we can
collaborate with one another
and lastly it looks like building the
better future that we want to see this
is from my colleague and I being
recipients of the code for Science and
Society event fund Grant where in the
spring of 2023 we're going to be
bringing a Pathways to open science
programming to students from
historically black colleges and
universities hbcus of which I am an alum
thank you
and so all of that to say that a more
Equitable future for our field is
possible
but it's time for us to do the work
and so I'm leaving everyone in this room
today with three action items and three
ways to to begin those conversations and
the first is the center of the voices of
those we work to support and include
this is a time to listen this is a time
to amplify it's not a time to do
anything more than that
also to ask hard questions in the rooms
where you do have a voice
look at your organization at your hiring
structure at your onboarding process and
ask yourself some of those questions
where are people following through the
cracks where can we do better
what needs to happen for our team to
include everyone at any level
and lastly be the Community member who
you want to meet at the beginning of
your journey
had I not met Julie I would not be
standing in front of you all today
and so I encourage you all to be a Julie
and also to continue to perpetuate
community and provide this inclusive
space at every level of leadership at
every level of Engagement so that no
matter what angle someone enters our our
studio community at or enters the data
science community at that they feel
included and that we're ready to work
together
and so while I stand before you all
today as one of you
I strongly believe that leveraging our
community I can be one of many
and with that I would like to sincerely
thank and acknowledge everyone who made
presenting in front of you all today
possible so I'd like to thank Julie and
the openscapes team I'd like to thank
the r Studio diversity Scholars and I
would also like to thank Makai Fort and
my support system who made sure even
though I just took my PhD comprehensive
exams last week and I passed that I was
still here
thank you thank you
uh that I was still able and ready to be
standing in front of you all today and
give this presentation
and so with that I'm happy to take any
questions I'd love to connect with you
all I'd love to work with you all and
I'm and I'm ready to take any questions
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]